[Music]
hey guys and welcome to unmasking the
masked singer now that the Superbowl is
finally over we can talk about the real
competition tonight the season three
premiere of the mass singer I'm Charlie
O'Keeffe and I'm Deidre Behar that is
right the Super Bowl has a champion
congrats to this sorry Congrats to the
Chiefs and we have your first masked
singer elimination from season three now
we're gonna be your referees for the
night we're gonna guide you through all
the major plays from the huge group a
premiere that's right and just a warning
if you haven't watched the premiere yet
we are about to give away a major I mean
the one and only spoiler give us the
alarm on our new sound board this season
that's your warning we're gonna give it
away
hey Deidre do you happen to know what a
robot's favorite type of music is I do
not well it's heavy metal
IATA what while I recover from that
incredible joke let's take a look at the
first unmasking
[Music]
[Applause]
Weezy F baby did you have any idea a few
of the clues that you actually brought
up to me I think so the song titles in
there but other than that no this is a
huge name though yeah I mean this is
pretty incredible that the masked singer
producers were able to secure Lil Wayne
and the fact that Lil Wayne wanted to do
this show is a really big feat now I'm a
huge hip-hop fan the second the I'm
sorry the second the robot started
singing I knew this was Lil Wayne I've
been a fan for years he's got such a
distinct and recognizable voice there
were a few clues in the clue package I
don't even think it's really necessary
you know the fire truck obviously his
song fireman um he mentioned let it rock
he has a song called let it rock with
Kevin Rudolph but again it really just
came down to the vocals for me what do
you think I thought the judges guesses
were actually very interesting I mean
Johnny put johnny Knoxville Jamie Foxx
who is the guest panelist tonight said
Stevo and Nicole said Floyd Mayweather
yeah close but no cigar that is wheezy
and I think it's cool you know he's got
four children this is such a great show
that you can watch whether your kids or
that you can do to impress your kids
totally because I don't know he probably
signed NDA's and I doubt all four of
them knew that he was doing this no I
mean Jenni and Robin had been teasing us
the past few weeks we've seen in
commercials and promos on social media
that this first unmasking was going to
be huge yeah and it was yes they lived
up to it completely they deliver and
with an unmasking as huge as little
Wayne there are surely some huge names
under the remaining costumes but Before
we jump into our next five performers
let's take a look at the group a B and C
bracket that was revealed during
tonight's premiere that is right for the
first time we are now seeing which of
the 18 costumes will be facing off
against each other for the competition
in the remaining months Group A who we
saw tonight included the white tiger the
turtle miss monster the llama the
kangaroo and our first eliminated the
robot Group B includes the banana
elephant frog mouse taco my personal
favorite the kitty
and finally for Group C it includes the
t-rex the astronaut the Swan the bear
the night angel and the Rhino and now
remember what this new format will be
seeing group a for the next few weeks
until we reach our top three performers
and then the same will happen for Group
B and C later on eventually we will end
up with our top
math singers I love that they're doing
it this way this season I can't wait to
spend more time with all the people we
got to meet tonight but for now let's
get back to the costumes that we saw our
next performer certainly had the eye of
the tiger there during his first
appearance take a look
gut instinct what's a telling you my gut
instinct was Tom Brady of the New
England Patriot arleigh let me tell you
why
Nick Cannon before this I know I know
it's a stretch guys before the first
performer
Nick Cannon said that tonight there are
nine Super Bowl appearances alone in
Group A the only person with nine Super
Bowl appearances happens to be Tom Brady
right but I'm gonna tell you why that
doesn't necessarily work because it
could be more than just one NFL player
so it could be an amalgam of Super Bowl
appearances from different people okay
let's get into the clue package the
first thing that tipped me off was this
clam shocking blue that immediately
reminds me of the East Coast
particularly New England so like you
another Patriot my brain went to the
Patriots but when I saw this person
perform big energy big movements this is
someone who's also really tall II
noticeably taller than Nick Cannon Nick
Cannon's about six-one this person's at
least six foot three or taller I'm going
with Gronk on this one Rob Gunn Krauss
Gronkowski what do you think I I'm
agreeing with Gronk and there were a few
other things that pointed to that as
well we saw a masked singer tryout sign
and it had five three now obviously they
want us to thank fifth month Thursday
I'm not going with that Gronk's last
Super Bowl that he appeared in and one
was Super Bowl fifty three okay that
makes a lot of sense totally okay you
saw a few others on the clam trophy
there was actually the number 51 he also
competed in the 51st Super Bowl and won
that one as well I like it and finally
let's party we heard that it's something
the Patriots coach has said before and
Gronk has also said it in a commercial I
believe - I mean Gronk is the poster boy
for partying he's at the Super Bowl this
weekend in Miami throw in his own beach
party my last thing my last takeaway
that I think it is Gronk is the phrase
smashed the competition he said that
during the clue package and if you know
Gronk if you know the way that he played
football he loves a dramatic touchdown
moment he would always throw the ball
down with so much force and so much
energy and that's kind of what I saw
translated into his dance moves I'm
going with Gronk and I think we can
definitely all agree this is an athlete
no offense Gronk
if this is you not a singer but a fun
performer a fun performer I took it a
step further
rob gronkowski guys he's actually
performed ice ice baby before in the
past all songs and if you look it up it
didn't exactly go that well he forgot
the lyrics so I think this could be like
a fun Redemption performance okay I
really did kill this one it was pretty
fun well next up we have a performer who
certainly came out of his shell to
serenade the audience with Seal's kiss
from a rose take a look
[Applause]
well first of all this is already the
best season ever because you know I am a
die-hard co-owner sat over there the
seal is framed on our new set here this
song automatically it requires someone
who's got vocal chops this is a really
challenging song with a lot of
challenging up-and-down riffs I was
really stumped right off the bat I did
not know who this was but my best guess
is Jesse McCartney I'm sticking my teen
heartthrob from my insane vocals yeah
well we know Jesse can sing for sure I
want to go to the clue package really
quickly there was a moment where we saw
burgers so we see the turtle is like
frying up some burgers and I was like
what is Jesse McCartney have to do with
burgers well if you're a fan of the show
young and hungry which formerly aired on
freeform he played a character who had a
scene that involved burgers yeah so I
was like okay that's totally plausible
my other big thing tipping me off for
Jesse McCartney was the bunny ears I
think we have a shot of the masked
singer DJ security detail wearing their
bunny ears so get this Jesse McCartney
born in the year 1987 which is the year
of the rabbit a subtle possible clue if
I do say so much and now one that gave
it away from me it was the the surfboard
we saw him with which obviously stuck
out in this clue package I mean a
surfboard there on a track what I got
from that was he has a Teen Choice Award
guys he's teen heartthrob Teen Choice
Award it goes together also he acted on
summer land when he played a surfer yeah
I loved it I loved that one I absolutely
think it's Jesse McCartney the skills
the clues are you on board with us let
us know sir I want to get into our next
character performer get ready to ring
via llama
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
fun song choice right off the bat the
judges shock factor I think was my
favorite they're like he's about to sing
this he did well he teed it up but it
was gonna be a song about romance and
then you choose Ricky Martin she bangs
who do you think this is I'm going with
drew Carey and I will tell you why so
one of the first things we saw in that
clue package was obviously most
predominately shown right at the
beginning was a radio station 23.3 well
drew Carey obviously the Drew Carey Show
it ran for 233 episodes that makes sense
doesn't it that's a giveaway for me what
about you I also think it's drew Carey a
lot of the evidence was pointing towards
him so there was a Seattle record cover
mm-hmm
do we have yes that's it right there the
23.3 the wall yes but there was also a
yes that's it right there Seattle the
city Seattle has significance to Drew
Carey's life because he is a minority
stakeholder in a Seattle MLS soccer team
so that totally and I believe the
Seattle Sounders correct pretty much
that just yes and also I saw a Buddha
drew is a practicing Buddhist so that
may be another clue right and my last
one that kind of tipped me off was the
whole pottery thing that was going on I
was like go spy yeah it was like does
Drew Carey a big Patrick Swayze
like what's going on here but actually
on the Drew Carey Show they see if
there's an episode where they seek out a
senior rec center and they meet a
pottery teacher named woody who they
both want to set their moms up with so
there was and I could be completely
wrong let us know if you think that
we're crazy but I think all signs are
kind of pointing to Drew Carey it's also
a funny costume he had a funny comedic
take and we know he's a comedian again
not someone who's a professional singer
like we saw with the last one but I
think it gave a performance that
definitely nods to a comedian or someone
of a Drew Carey vibe and I thought one
of the judges guesses particularly stuck
out Ken said Joe McHale
who we've obviously seen on season one
and two as a guest panelist yeah I okay
here's the thing with Joel McHale he's
like six foot six yep so immediately I
would have probably been a little jarred
if I had noticed this person was six
llama
I love Joel McHale I know he's a fan of
the show and a friend of the show I'm
still sticking with Drew Carey on this
documentary Carrie as well
yep now the next cost
may look a bit familiar because it's
someone from the monster family
following t-pain's season one win listen
to miss monster
[Applause]
obviously someone who can see one who
can sing and to be honest when this
performer first came out I was like I
think it's a kid I think it's someone
keyed someone young someone maybe a teen
just because the costume looked so small
this is someone who has been oh I know
this is someone who has had a long yeah
who were you leaning towards so I just
watched the Grammys we covered the
Grammys and Tanya Tucker had a huge
moment at the Grammys so she's kind of
fresh in my mind
I'm going with her for a few reasons
number one there's a 10 on the locker so
if we can throw up that clip real quick
yes she's in front of these lockers and
you see there's a 10 there's also an 11
I don't really know what the 11s for but
10 definitely has significance Tonya's
birthday is October 10th so 10 10 I was
like determined to figure out what 11
means the only thing I could come up
with is that between the year she was
born in the year she started singing was
when she was 11 years old it was 11
years okay so it could be a huge stretch
there I do think the number 10 is a
winner but 11 I'm still a little shaky
on what do you think I think the voice
definitely is something that stuck out
she has a very notable and recognizable
voice which I am definitely picking up
on but also going back to what Nick
Cannon said at the start about seeing 9
Super Bowl appearances in Group A
appearances could mean someone who was
in the stance and got photographed a
celebrity someone who's singing the
national anthem performer who did
halftime well miss Tanya Tucker did in
1994 the Super Bowl halftime show okay
so add that to the list
we've got Tanya Tucker add up to the
Super Bowl list on the other big clue
that tipped me off was she ended the
clue package by saying would you still
love me like you used to
that's definitely a nod to her song it's
also the album title of her 1980s 1987
album album titles are a big one song
titles and album album titles definitely
give us a route to go down one
particular singer I know that we're not
definitive but do you feel like this is
challenging enough I feel like we're
finding a lot of stuff online I'm
finding a lot online I know they said it
was gonna be less google-able
yeah I'm still googling I mean I'm
getting some text from friends who are
watching tonight as well yeah I think
it's this person we're googling as well
people are looking and people are
searching but I mean with so many
some people watching the show everyone's
gonna find things out online mm-hmm for
sure and finally our last singer of the
night had me kangaroo ting for whoever
is underneath the mask
check out this emotional performance
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so this voice like almost made me
tear up this is someone who's been
through something it's a it's a powerful
song it's an emotional song and a very
emotional performance I'm going
Jordin Sparks Jordin Sparks who I would
love to see on the show I'm going with
Jordin Sparks as well just because I
want to see her do the mass singer I
mean she's someone with true vocal
ability and you know the girl has been
through a lot both good and bad over the
last couple of years my first big notice
of her costume was the kangaroo baby
pouch and we know Jordan actually had a
baby of 2018 she got married in 2017 so
those being the positive life changes
that she's experienced but the clew
package was rather sad and it broke my
heart into a million pieces seeing her
talk about being a survivor and having
gone through a lot of loss in the past
few years Jordan actually lost not one
two three but actually four people in a
single week her stepsister her cousin
and her two friends and she heard a
really lengthy beautiful Instagram
tribute to them at the time so this is
someone who has definitely overcome loss
heartache and and some challenges in
their life and I felt that in that
emotional vocal performance I mean that
cover was beautifully done it was sung
perfectly I loved all of that I do want
a recording of that one if it is her
Jordan please get on that one that I
particularly dug into was the gramophone
so we saw a gramophone kind of like
leaning on a tree in the outside clue
package if we can get that up as well
there it is
the gramophone she's only been nominated
for one Grammy which first of all is a
crime a crime a crime it was the 51st
annual Grammy Awards in 2008 for Best
Pop Collaboration with vocals for the oh
so iconic song no air a great mom who I
would love to see her sing as well I
love that you know we we saw so many
things that alluded to her in the glue
package the jump rope I loved because
I'm so into like health and fitness and
I know Jordans been on a huge health
journey she's obsessed with jump rope
that's at like how she gets her
cardiovascular in so I don't know I feel
all the signs are pointing to her and
this would be another one of those
performers kind of like a Michelle
Williams who is doing the show to kind
of like have a reamer gence and to be
rebirthed and show the world that I'm
doing okay yeah and I would love to see
her obviously let us know if you think
it's Jordin Sparks I think the voice is
there but also not there I believe it's
her but it could be anyone else at this
point
yep well it's been a more than eventful
Superbowl Sunday and I am seriously
excited what what the rest of the season
has to offer and of course we want to
know who you think is on the show this
season we've only seen 6 out of the 18
performers so there's still plenty of
guessing to do and of course don't
forget there is another new episode this
Wednesday that is only a few days away
from now we will be back market and
another singer from Group A will be
eliminated of course guys let us know
who you think the remaining singers are
using the hashtag ET mass singer and we
will see you on Wednesday
cheers to a great season guys
[Music]